stadt berlin ist aufgeteilt unter dem
araber clans prostitution waffenhandel
geldwäsche schutzgeld jeder hat sein
territorium
haben sie angst vor der familie geschah
die polizei ist machtlos gegen diese
plant man erst richtig gesehen habe das
war nach 23 monaten
ich fand das nicht schlimm
wann ist durcheinander
wann kommt hin man erwartet ein bisschen
hilfe irgendwo auch verständlich weil
jetzt starb ich möchte ich bin in ruhe
gelassen wir haben hier in einem der
gefährlichsten orte der welt vor dem
reaktorblock tschernobyl 1986 in der
nacht explodierte
[Musik]
sie sollten astronauten 384 1400
kilometer zum mond und wieder zurück
wird ein wunder
[Musik]